[Musique]
vous m'avez raconter la guerre la terre
qui tremblaient le ciel qui brûlait
[Musique]
mais ceux qui ont survécu
qui se sont réveillés dans un monde
différent
où les forts écrasent les faibles mais
ça ne doit pas être comme ça quand je
t'ai trouvé ton cerveau très humain
était miraculeusement intactes on se
sent salle quand on sait pas qui en est
la mémoire de reviendra
[Musique]
m
à l'état une nouvelle ici elle a
beaucoup à apprendre c'est un monde sans
pitié
je vais te montrer quelque chose
[Musique]
ce corps je me sens relié à lui je peux
pas l'expliquer vous en savez plus sur
moi que venelles dit les lieux des
choses qui ne vaut mieux oublier à 8 ans
je les découvrirai tout seul
malika sur ce toit
[Musique]
mon dieu
elle est la dernière elle est tournée
logis qui ont séparé depuis trois
siècles
elles menacent l'ordre naturel des
choses
amical ils vont s'en prendre à toi
alors je vais devoir les affronter
tu dois aller plus loin possible
ce soir on joue pas
chasse il faut l'éliminer vient de
commettre la plus grosse erreur de ta
fille
je suis avec elle